[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode Kos
and I am so I can't even and I never
thought this day would happen you know
when you're reading comic books as a kid
you really don't think what this
returning to what what it would become
you don't think about movies you just
think about your little action figures
hopefully they make a toy out of the
characters that you love and you like
hopefully that you know they keep them
around in the books and and they grow
with you throughout the years and I'll
never forget I'm getting ahead of myself
I I am getting ahead of myself let me
introduce to you sideshows Premium
Format Colossus you know we don't get
into the statue today did we going to
get into the statue today I'm gonna give
a big shout-out to Smitty Smith a member
of the realm a watcher of iron Lords
podcast and family to us at the iron
Lords he correctly picked the statue
that I will be displaying this week so
Smitty Smith shout-out to you brother
anyway let's get back to this statue so
like I was saying you never know or how
your characters are gonna grow with you
listen I never even thought that statues
of this magnitude would be able to be
made but let me go back to when I was
first introduced to this character and
why
he is so near and dear to my heart I was
going through the comic book racks I
picked up a giant-size x-men number one
had Wolverine on the cover that had a
metal guy a black woman with wings which
I later found out was storm had
Nightcrawler had what is that a
Thunderbird you know so I said what is
this what is this no excellent wonder
what is this the new x-men all-new x-men
now remember Wolverine from when he
fought the Hulk right okay but who's
this guy who's this metal guy and that
was the first time I was introduced to
Pedro
Rasputin Peter his American name is
short straight from the motherland of
Russia and reading the story I was like
yo I'm so into this destroying man real
Strummer because the x-men really didn't
have a strongman the old that's when the
original x-men you had what uh the
beasts come on he's not a real strong
man he's the agile fast character and
you know now you have Wolverine and
Nightcrawler for that part but you
needed a real strong man and then the
next book where I was completely all in
I'm a John Romita fan I told you guys it
was x-men 183 where it was like a gay
guy's day out and Wolverine set up
Colossus to let off some steam and fight
in the juggernaut and they were in a bar
and it was it was probably one of my
best
Colossus juggernaut fights the storyline
was good you know it was it was such a
good read but this character has sought
ups and downs this character has saved
the mutant race from the legacy virus
the
character has lost the love of his life
this character has also become the
unstoppable juggernaut so I know right
that's a tale for another day but let's
talk about what's on his shoulder
lucky Lockheed is a dragon that belongs
with KT pride now when I go into deeper
with the statue
I'm willing to explain why it's on his
shoulder let's get into the statue so
when I'm unboxing the statue I'm like
man this box is heavy
man for Premium Format man this box is
heavy okay so I get to the unboxing and
I take it out and I'm like man the base
is solid and heavy oh my god the the
statue himself is heavy
his hands are South this is like I paid
$700 for the statue
i'ma tell you right now this is probably
the best Premium Format that they put
out probably the best I mean you have
something kept out that are fantastic
that are outrageous but I think I don't
man maybe because I love the statue so
much but I'm telling you the physique on
this character is sideshows best
physique
I thought Superman had the best physique
the sideshow put out the anatomy on this
character the the sense of strength the
presence of strength the chest the
shoulders the back the arms the triceps
the biceps the thighs the man never
misses leg day is incredible the bass is
part of the juggernaut statue what does
it pull the danger wound or Rama where
you have role yeah
gambits you have Colossus and you have
the juggernaut so far I don't know who
else they're gonna have in that line I
only have two so far I don't know if I'm
gonna get the other two
I really like the rogue but I will like
a DX version now lucky the reason why
Lockheed is on this because Lockheed has
always traveled with Peter he's Katie
prides dragon that she got when they
went to go save Peters sister Ileana
from the demon Belasco and she got him
in the demon world and he just stuck
around very powerful dragon very
powerful and always stood on the side
you know always was really by side so it
only stands that if she's part of the
juggernaut door Rama then Lockheed the
e.x version is part of Peters Colossus
so this is the part in the video when
I'm gonna tell you to like follow
subscribe and also go to loads of gaming
dotnet where we have all the information
on the statue
price artists sculpt dimensions so you
can understand what you're getting
yourself into when you decide to
purchase this statute and if you're a
fan of the artist you can see all the
information are loads of gaming dotnet
we have a ton of writers there we have
old episodes of kos also of Lords of
game Annette is home to the iron Lords
podcast while I'm a member of so you can
also check us out there and you can see
the last word we're loyal Cognito and in
Pontus but before you leave hit there
join but if that joint button you
thought I was gonna forget now I'm not
gonna forget hit that joint button so
you could be part of the realm
like my man Smith Smith who's there
every Sunday showing his support like
countless others it is truly humbling
stick around watch the rest of this
video
and tune in next week
why can't the statue that I had sitting
on the side but your man bump them on a
spot stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]